as covert 19's global impact mounts so
does the urgent need to stop it spread a
vaccine is what we need for life to get
back to some sort of semblance of
normality the scientists are working as
quickly as they can but that's at least
a year a year and a half two years away
in the meantime scientists are trying
existing drugs to treat Kove at 19
[Music]
the corona virus which causes cove at 19
was only identified in January this year
a mysterious pneumonia outbreak in China
has been identified it's from the same
family that caused the deadly SARS
epidemic 17 years ago but scientists
have known about corona viruses since
the 1960s giving them a head start and
understanding
and that meant that when this current
new strain appeared there was quite a
lot of understanding of the basic
biology SARS CoV - which is the new
corona virus has a very similar
structure to previous current viruses
and by understanding the biology and
structure of that virus we can start to
look for ways to attack the virus has an
outer membrane made up of fatty
molecules which scientists called lipids
spike proteins float on this lipid
membrane and provide the virus particle
with the appearance of a crown giving
the corona virus its name inside is a
molecule of RNA a chemical similar to
DNA on which the virus's genome is
written when the virus gets inside the
body the Spike proteins link up with the
proteins found on the surface of cells
in the lungs Airways this lets the virus
break into the patient cells inside it
releases the RNA that carries the
virus's genes those genes hijack the
cell's protein making machinery to
produce the building blocks for more
virus particles one specific gene could
replicate provides the instructions to
build a molecular machine the copies the
viruses RNA making enough for up to
1,000 new virus particles the new
particles are then released from the
cell to attack other cells spreading the
virus it's this replication that has
become a focus for scientists searching
for an effective treatment the
replicated system within the virus is
actually a good target for disrupting
how the virus works because healthy
human cells don't actually copy RNA
within them so what you could do is if
you could disrupt the replication system
in the virus you'd hopefully destroy the
virus
without harming human cells
but developing a new drug from scratch
that could do this and running the
trials needed to ensure the drug is safe
for humans could take months or even
years during the pandemic every month
you spend trying to do research more
people will potentially suffer or die
and so that's why there's a move to try
and repurpose existing drugs if you've
already got the drug available for
something else you know that it's
probably safe for humans and so you can
speed up the whole process one of the
drugs seen as most promising is called
REM des aver it was originally developed
to treat Ebola by blocking the replicate
system it was found to be safe for
humans but was shelved in favor of a
more effective treatment the molecules
in rem des aver looked like the
molecules that the replicate system uses
to make RNA when this drug gets into a
cell the virus tries to use the drug
molecules to replicate and then it
basically doesn't work so the virus
doesn't manage to replicate properly
and there are other drugs on the market
that scientists believe could also make
it harder for the virus to replicate
itself
there's also another drug called
collector which is used to treat HIV at
the moment in combination with other
therapies it was tried during the
original SARS outbreak in 2003 and
seemed to offer some benefits what that
does is target the enzymes that chop up
big proteins into smaller proteins
during the replication process of a
virus and so if you can disrupt that
perhaps that's another way to stop it
from replicating within cells both
friend is a ver and collector and now
being tested as part of a global mega
trial set up by the World Health
Organization in March the w-h-o study
will also put the anti-malarial cleric
REM to the test President Donald Trump
has built up a lot of hype around
hydroxychloroquine a similar drug which
works in the same way we're going to be
able to make that drug available almost
immediately based on what I see it could
be a game-changer
but the president's enthusiasm is
damaging the ill-informed in the lab it
seems chloroquine may reduce the virus
particles ability to get into cells and
to reproduce but in patients there is no
strong evidence as yet that the drug can
treat kovat 19 the w-h-o study should
provide a definitive answer and
chloroquine and the other drugs is
testing what the World Health
Organization is trying to do is speed up
the process by just trying more people
and that will hopefully allow them to
pick up even very marginal benefits of
the drugs pick up very small side
effects as well and then using all of
that information it might just help
these systems understand how to reduce
the number of days someone's infected
reducing the number of days someone is
Elfa can prove vitally important
even very small differences in the
length of time someone's ill can have
enormous knock-on benefits for a health
system if you can knock five days after
the amount of time someone needs to be
in hospital or needs a ventilator
you can treat more people with the same
number of ventilators of the same number
of doctors an effective vaccine is the
only definitive way to halt the spread
of coronavirus the world the world waits
for that repurposing existing drugs
could help doctors tree set allowing
patients health systems in countries
that are coming under intolerable strain
to find a little respite
we're dedicated to bringing you the most
up-to-date reporting and analysis on
this rapidly changing story so clicking
on the link opposite will take you to
all of our coronavirus coverage thank
you for watching
you